I think I'm going to take a little bit
of time to write today.
bit about what I've done in the last
three weeks.
I think I have a uh a pretty solid
plan
going forward with the next steps for
Puffer
on the uh the core development side. At
the very least,
it's also been three quite difficult
weeks of work.
I think that's what we're going to do.
I'm going to write an article. I'm going
to see how I feel in the process and uh
if the mood takes me, I will start on
some of the experimental analysis
and some optimizations to tuning. And if
not, then I won't.
We shall see.
Yeah, the looking swole thing is uh
well, to be fair, I actually don't know
if it's the exercise, the cut, or the
3-w week block of work, but I am getting
quite tired. Taking a toll. So, I'm
going to have to take a couple days off
soon at some point, but I don't know if
the days off should be from research,
diet, uh, training, or all of the above.
We shall see. Welcome, Tim.
well, it's too early to say whether this
sweep is any good, I suppose.
How did the experiments go? The
experiments are going. I need to do a
little bit more info work on our hyper
pram tuning
to support what I have in mind, though.
Yeah, writing article. All right, stop
spamming the the troll thing.
I'm going to write this article for as
long as I feel like writing this
article. We shall see.
Yeah, exactly. That's That's what I'm
doing, man. That's the point.
Do you batch updates to Neural MMO?
Just a coincidence. Puffer 3 and Neural
MO 3. Actually, Neural MMO 3 came out
with Puffer 2.
excited for this watching your work the
last few weeks. Yeah, I think I'm hoping
I can write this today. What's today?
Wednesday
and then we'll see how I feel from
I did come across one. Popper two was
around. Didn't have the RL brain worm
back then. Watch your thesis. Remembered
it when I got the edge. Yeah, you're
doing cool stuff. I hope to see a couple
of these physics sims prarded. Be nice.
I kind of like the way that I work on
stuff. I kind of just have to get
completely focused in on something for a
few weeks at a time. And the last three
weeks has been uh on all this research.
Basically figuring out everything I'm
writing in this article.
And then I'm going to have to go like at
least take some days off or do something
else for a bit. We'll see.
I think that I think people are going to
be happy with this though when I finish
writing this. This is a lot of
information that's not
I don't even think widely known. It's
just not known at
hard every time. Writing is not that
hard, Tim.
This type of writing actually took me
quite a bit longer to learn because um I
did a lot a lot of writing when I was
younger, but it was creative writing.
technical writing took longer. Now, this
actually this is a lot easier to learn,
I think, than academic writing because
academic writing is like you kind of
just have to learn [ __ ] right? I
don't have to write [ __ ] here. Like
here, I just have to think about writing
the stuff that I want like conveying the
information I want without regard to
anything else.
There is welcome.
I started watching the long video
introducing Pupper Lib. What long video?
I have a few different ones. Some of
them are newer, some of them are older.
The iceberg video is still a pretty fun
intro.
Does the size of the reward matter just
the difference
the lowest and the highest? Uh, it does
because you're directly using the reward
to compute like an advantage or a value
and you end up scaling things different.
I actually in Puffer by default I clamp
all rewards to negative one and one like
between those that interval just so
people don't completely mess it up.
the variance that m
uh you're going to end up having to
rescale stuff most likely. It depends on
the implementation
in practice. Um, what I do for all my
stuff is I define uh the reward for
different types of stuff to have. Like
look at neural MMO, right? There are a
few different reward signals for
leveling up and like getting equipment
and like dying or whatever. And I just
assign coefficients between negative one
and one to these. And then I
automatically tune those coefficients as
hyperparameters.
ML now I'm back not familiar with RL
what's a great intro
way ahead of you my guy
my guide is right here written exactly
to answer that
Why on earth would it do it that is
horrible?
Why would it ever do that?
Why does it do this with the the
scaling?
The Wi-Fi is not very good.
That's kind of a problem for a
CS lab, don't you think?
How much time does it take a chest
engine? Uh, I don't know what that is.
ED roam until I get my I see. Yeah.
Have I told you about the uh the latest
they start this since RLC?
Yeah, literally since RLC. The uh
batshit fitness thing since RLC.
All right, so Ryan, here's the uh here's
the the current project,000
plus calorie a day cut. So it's actually
probably close to 1500. I'm losing like
two to four pounds a week.
Uh,
five days a week, six mile run on the
dish hills.
Five days a week of lifting, including a
set of uh, deadlifts every one of those
days, plus bench, weighted pull-ups,
bunch of other stuff.
Um, and then a longer run on the weekend
where my longest one so far has been 16
miles.
This has been the last three and a half
weeks.
How much time is the chess engine
learning through RL to beat humans? It
depends which humans.
We have a couple different people
working on um RL chess actually right
now in the Discord.
realistically,
until I either have no more visible fat
or until I start losing strength.
You sure would be my bulk.
Um, good question.
I honestly
I'm probably on not that much more than
like 1500 calories a day. It can't
possibly be your bulk.
Like I literally will have
I have like a bagel sandwich
and
a bowl of chicken, like a big bowl of
chicken uh chicken and rice soup and
some chips and salsa. And that's it on a
day-to-day basis.
Well, it's just starting to catch up to
me a little bit, Tim. That like a 1500
deficit? It probably is. I assume it's
possible that I'm counting wrong, right?
I could be up to like 2,000 or something
and burning 3,000, but it's at least
1,00 cal deficit.
Maybe save the L.
Well, we'll see.
I don't know. I might do an article on
the uh the point of this there actually
was a pretty substantial point behind
this though.
So, the reason that I'm doing this,
right,
the story behind this uh is that when I
went to Nurips last year,
um I was bulked to
190 pounds at about 14% body fat. You
know, I had a few extra pounds on me,
but I was also, you know, I was fit, I
was strong. I just come off of running a
50k, hitting a thousand total, starting
to get a good 5k time, right? And then I
got pneumonia
and uh I lost like 18 pounds in two
weeks. And because I was being pumped
full of the wrong kind of steroids to
keep me alive, uh it all came out of
muscle. So, when you go down to
170 pounds and you lose it all from
muscle, congratulations, your body fat
percentage has gone up by a few percent,
right? And uh yeah, it sucks to have to
cut that amount of fat. But I wasn't
going to cut it then because like I'm
not going to cut from 170 pounds back to
150 pounds. Then I'm kind of just
screwed because then I got to do a 40
pound bulk. So, what I did is I tried
best as I could to get back to like
185ish and I did, you know, I put some
strength back on. I did some running. I
got myself into decent shape, but I
still had basically the same amount of
fat. So, now at least now I can cut down
from 185 to something reasonable so I
don't get to be a stick in the process.
Uh, and then I can do a slow bulk back
up.
out.
At the very least, I have a decent
excuse for this cuz literally uh like
there's no possible way I would have
ended up with that amount of fat any
other way.
Yeah, absolutely sucks.
I will say though, the training history
makes it substantially easier to get
back into shape than it was to get into
shape the first time.
And I'm also happy I beat my um I beat
my old I'm pretty sure I beat my old PR
for one loop on the dish and without
even like a crazy amount of effort. So,
at the very least, right, I know that
there's like not permanent damage
um from that, which is good.
I could go train for a marathon like
just to see, you know, to make sure I
can do the long distance, but honestly,
I need like some more stuff to go wrong.
You kind of need to be in a really bad
You kind of need some [ __ ] to go wrong
if you're training for a marathon cuz
that thing sucks. You kind of need
something to be mad about. And I'm kind
of chilling at the moment.
Anything over 20 miles just gets to be
freaking brutal.
that was hard
training for one.
My first marathon I did I the longest
run I had done before my marathon was 16
miles and I basically just like got up
in the morning and decided screw it, I'm
running a marathon today.
The second marathon that I ran, I felt
absolutely terrible that day. I got six
miles into my what was supposed to be a
nine mile run and said, "Screw it. I'm
running a marathon today."
The 50k
um I knew I was going to do at least a
marathon. I didn't know. I thought maybe
I could do longer. I maybe do a 50k and
I got through to the marathon and I'm
like, "Ah, screw it. Okay, I'm just
doing the full 50k
and that's how all of my long distances
have gone.
That's short for me. I do long slow
races. Okay, you do ultras. That's a
different story.
Yeah, ultras are a totally different
story
pretty much. That's
honestly if you're not in shape for like
the really long runs, even doing a 50k,
like I lost fitness doing my 50k.
Can I ask your height and weight, Tim?
Cuz the other thing that I just don't
feel like doing is I think in order to
be able to do longer distances
effectively without completely breaking
my knees, I'd have to cut way more
weight than I'm willing to.
63.
Holy [ __ ] Wait.
So that was my weight. 3 in taller than
you
in high school when I was like a stick.
So that's like Yeah, that's still a way
way lighter. So let me think. What is my
Let me give it to you in metric.
So I am 175.
Oh, 5'8. Oh, I did the conversion wrong
then. Never mind. Oh [ __ ] Yeah, that's
super light. Yeah, that's literally
that's exactly what I was in high school
then, right? That grew like an extra
inch. So that's literally exactly what I
was in high school.
Yeah. So, you can think that I'm up more
than 20 kilograms from that, right? Like
up more than 20 kilograms from that.
All right. So, my heaviest Tim is uh 86
kg
at basically your same height, one inch
taller.
Yeah, it does make you slow. It's very
very difficult to get the speed on that.
But yeah, I'm not willing to cut my
weight um enough. And like I also don't
necessarily enjoy the long distance
running. I It's kind of I do it more
out of spite than anything.
I enjoy the strength stuff a lot more.
What is that? YouTube formatting.
What YouTube format?
Oh yeah. I don't know what the heck.
86 is fine if it's muscle. It was fairly
lean uh when I hit it right before I got
sick.
I'm trying to get there at like, you
know,
if I can get to there at 11% body fat,
then I'll be very happy. That's the
goal.
Long as running is dummy. My father did
Western States twice, so it's like,
well, [ __ ] I'm not going to go do that
now, am I?
I honestly after the 50k that I did,
like I honestly wouldn't even want to do
more 50ks unless I'm in shape to do
longer distances because I feel like if
you do an event that's like pushing your
maximum distance, you just lose fitness.
It's not good for you.
Is that a 250? What the
price, man? You are in good shape then.
Holy hell.
That is that is actually continuous,
isn't it?
125 hours.
That's actually continuous. That's
batshit insane.
Yeah, that's like that's completely
insane.
Holy [ __ ] And 40,000 feet elevation
gained. That's nuts.
Yeah, that's crazy. Okay, you're in very
good shape for that.
That's not just stubbornness like that's
you have to be in crazy ass shape.
Hey, captain.
I didn't even know that there was a 250.
That's batshit.
The hardest race I knew about was the
the Barkley Marathons.
now you're good
is the main other thing I do honestly
sparkly is harder to finish really well
I guess that course is just insane
Right.
Yeah, I was pretty happy just finishing
the damn 50K. I have an article on X.
Like, not by your standards. Uh I not
not hard by your standards, I'm sure,
but it wasn't like an easy course for
your, you know, your average 50k.
It was like 500 feet elevation per 5K or
whatever. It's like a pretty hilly
course.
this article on yeah this is article on
stuff I found out captain
I'm kind of just writing this today and
chilling is the uh and like checking
some experiments
do you not just like lose 30 pounds in
the course of that
Yeah.
Well, 50k that was
basically
two month training block, I think. And
that's about the most I can do is to be
like a twomonth training block out from
something like that, right?
see if I can find you the the course
real quick.
This back can't move for a week after.
I couldn't move for three days after
just the 50k. Yeah. So, it was this and
it was um I believe nine loops of this
course, which is a 5k here.
And yeah, so 4,300 ft elevation gain.
You can see this is slow as hell, right?
Super super slow as hell. Um
but yeah, this is like, you know, you
can see just the hills on each loop.
And this was
I think this was yeah this was the full
training block for it. Right.
So this is like
Yeah. This is about the shape that I'm
in right now is like this week right
here. This is about the shape I'm in
now. So, it would take me probably,
assuming no injuries, like a month and a
half if I wanted to do this again.
Um,
you can see block one, it's just six
miles five days a week, which is one lap
of the course that was going to be the
race course, right?
and then building up mileage on Sunday
run.
And then
same thing here, except I start adding
one extra loop on my Wednesday run.
And then I built to the longest training
run was 22 and a half miles. It's
probably a little bit under what it
should have been for a 50k. Honestly, I
probably could have afforded to do
another one of these blocks and get it
up to like a marathon distance for the
training run.
Yeah, lifting too.
I have uh
is this
I think this is like 24 what? Uh let me
give it to you in kilograms like 110 kg
or something.
Oh, yeah. I actually do have my times as
of that 50k. You can see I do not have
fast times on anything.
I did manage to get this 5k time down. I
believe it was like a I got the 5k time
down like to like a 23 or something I
believe uh at like a few months after
this cuz I didn't really train the short
distance at all. But you can see like
none of this stuff is fast.
30 kg. Gez. Yeah.
Honestly, the uh the benching plus
running, not that hard. Deadlifts plus
running, pretty damn hard. The thing
that I still can't do, and like I'm
literally not even training at the
moment because it's just too hard. I
can't squat and run. Squatting while
running is just the worst [ __ ]
imaginable.
Like I'm actually now during my
training, right, I'm deadlifting five
times a week, like one heavy set of five
per day.
And that's still nowhere near as bad.
And that's actually my strength test as
well, so I know when I need to stop
cutting is if I can't pull, what do I
have? So, I think that's like 335 now.
Yeah, 335. So, if I can't pull 335 for
five, then I know it's time to stop
cutting.
100k and it killed my
Yeah, it's uh
it's brutal. It's really brutal.
I will say that the running actually
carried quite well over to my squat
because when I started squatting again
after running it only took me a few
weeks to get a new PR on it up to
like 140 150 I don't know the exact
conversion no 330 is not kilos my god
that's pounds
for five and then my best was
uh so my best was like 85 for two.
The 335 now though is without without
straps, without a belt. It's just raw.
And it's done like literally 20 minutes
after I get back from running.
100 kg for five
to mount my back cuz I'm otherwise so
weak.
100 two plates I believe.
220. Yeah, it's two plates.
It's good to do some deadlifts.
I guess at your weight. Yeah,
at your weight
heavier would be questionable. I guess
at my weight it's like I don't start to
get worried about
potentially hurting stuff um under like
150 kg at all. Right. Heck, actually the
uh the 150 whatever it is I'm pulling is
154 or whatever. I don't even warm up
for that. I just do it cold. Well, I've
come back from my run, so I'm like warm,
but I don't do like I don't have any
warm-up weights for that at all.
Yeah, it's a totally different build,
Tim, right?
Like actually me getting fast now is
incredibly incredibly difficult because
I train know I train way better more
consistently harder with better sleep
and stuff now than I did when I was I
think when I set my best 5k time I was
16. I probably weighed like know under
60 kilos, right? Maybe two inches
shorter, few centimeters. Um,
and like I've not I've not gotten
I've not gotten close to that time and I
wasn't even a good runner. Like I was
not considered a good runner back then
at all. I think it was like um
like a 21 minute or something 5K.
I think it was like a 21 something and
then the best that I've set since then
is like a 23 something
on policy for the first mini batch. Uh
yes, Tim, but you can set it you can
just set it so that you're getting one
mini batch of samples from all your
ends.
Yeah, though. I mean, it's funny though
when I get people like you in here,
right? Like, you actually run ultras. I
do tell people I'm like not an
impressive uh athlete by any standards,
right? It's just like
this is what happens when somebody with
like very very average or below average
even genetics for any sort of
athleticism
just puts in
a reasonable amount of effort.
and like comparatively as well. I would
think that my
my lifting numbers are probably
probably no more impressive than my
running numbers. I would assume.
I actually don't know what fraction of
runners have done a distance over a
marathon versus like what fraction of
list lifters have hit a like a 1k total
at a reasonable body weight. I actually
don't know what the uh the fra the
relative fractions are.
But I would assume it's like pretty
similar.
Thought advantage was easy. Uh yeah, but
it is. I'll show you in a second.
I think I've now pretty thoroughly taken
apart puffer code with the exception of
binding code and advantage code. I need
to do that next.
Those are to be fair the two difficult
bits.
Those are kind of the two difficult
That's funny to me though that you
marathon is your short event.
I guess it probably is considering that
you're running your marathon. Like if
you're running your marathon twice as
fast as I am, then yeah, it's a short
event, right?
50k had me out in the sun for seven and
a half hours.
time to go. Got to see see you around,
Tim.
I suppose this one is like
reasonableish.
Oh, wait. No, this is not the same as
eight update epochs, right? No, no, no.
I have it totally wrong. Hang on.
So you roll out
1,024
and then you do 16
wait,24 over 16 is 64, right?
is eight.
you have publications? Yeah,
I have an MIT page with them. Um,
Puffer was recently published as well.
Why' you work on multi-agent
specifically in your PhD? Hey, Kevin.
Uh, cuz neural MMO, right? The whole the
whole idea around neural MMO
push environment complexity as much as
possible. I didn't really work on multi-
aent methods so much though if you think
of it. It's like it was more so to me
about getting more interesting
complexity into the environment, the
problems that we're studying. Okay.
You care about calibrating
probabilities.
What do you mean calibrating
probabilities? is
Have you seen the game Baby Bites?
No, I haven't.
Spirit says, "I've seen neural networks
outputs are not actual probabilities."
No, you just throw him through a
softmax.
Oh, I see what you mean. Yeah, we don't
care about that, though.
Like, that's
Yeah, I It's not relevant at all.
I mean I guess in like it could be
insupervised I guess but like
in RL you're using the output to select
actions right
so they are probabilities by definition
because that's what like that's how
you're sampling them you're sampling
them according to the softmax
and they're not true probabilities
of argument because doesn't have
calibration methods
data not up to date with modern
statistical inference. Nobody gives a
[ __ ] about modern statistical inference
though.
So
there you go.
Simulate small creatures. Learn feed
mate and avoid predators.
Somebody actually made this into a game.
It seems like
Oh, it's on itch.
Wait, did I just Is this made with Rayb?
Did I see this on
I was wondering if I saw this earlier
today.
Maybe not.
That's cool, though. Yeah, I've seen um
I've seen some stuff like this before.
This is a better version of it. This is
cool.
I mean data science in general as a
profession is
like a weird thing.
I know it's usually, at least my
impression generally is it's usually
just a combination of a bad programmer
and a mediocre statistician.
typically AI people are like researchers
or scientists or engineers, right?
Not business and engineering. Definitely
not that.
It's like
it's like math heavy people learned a
little bit of code
or I guess technically the other way the
other way around is kind of decent which
is like you know programmer who learned
a little bit of stats and is like like
that actually can be more valuable in my
mind because very often just nobody's
ever bothered to look at like literally
nobody's bothered to look at data and
you don't need to be a genius to like
throw really really basic stats onto
data that nobody's ever looked at and
get some cool insights
like that can work the other way around.
Well, I guess it's just cuz I have more
respect for um a lot of the engineering
than anything.
statisticians to learn coding.
The problem is I The problem is like
knowing a little stats lets you be
useful. Knowing a little programming
usually just lets you make a mess.
hands on videos to practice RL on the
channel for beginners. Uh the article as
is not videos just follow like the
article tells you exactly what to do as
well, what to read, what to study, what
to build.
engineers. Am I right? Yeah. But that's
the problem, right?
Like the way that you actually make that
stuff like stuff like this work is by
doing engineering to get access to data
that you wouldn't have had access to
before and then applying relatively
simple methods.
So it's like this weird in between. It's
like a really weird in between position.
I don't know.
I ask you questions regarding Pupper.
That is part of the reason I stream.
Yes, indeed.
This scientist understand the data and
theory better.
this. I don't know. The skill that I
have found the most useful overall
across like the largest variety of
different things is just being a good
programmer.
I don't know. Perhaps it's because some
of the stuff in research came a bit more
naturally. Perhaps it's because I did it
earlier and I don't remember all the
work I put in for that. But like
the vast majority of problems that I
find are just programming fails.
Is it only coded in Python?
No. Uh the training is in PyTorch which
has a Python front end but is internally
executing C++ and CUDA uh and it's doing
so in large batches which is minimizing
the amount of interaction with Python.
The uh data collection is
multi-processed
uh as a set of vectorzed array
operations in shared memory and all the
environments are written in pure C um
with at least some level of
optimization.
Uh we have a few specific optimizations
we apply to make them efficient for RL
usage as well.
So no this whole li this library would
not work if the whole thing were just
written in Python including the
environments.
Yep. Puffer is completely open source
and free to use
make money out of it. It was completely
free. Yeah, I do make revenue from
Puffer, but not just from like, oh yeah,
I'm using Puffer. Here's money, right?
It's we do work with companies that see
Puffer, want to do RL internally, and
see that we have the fastest tools and
that we offer services around them.
It depends on your experience, right?
Like
I don't think it's arrogant for me to
say that there a singledigit number of
people in the world that could have made
puffer lib.
It's like a very specific combination of
findings and insights accumulate over
accumulated over the last decade of my
work.
Uh, I mean the company could be
technically though
I wouldn't I'm not looking to just like
sell Puffer and move on, right? My goal
with Puffer is to solve the problems
with this field and make it broadly
useful.
I mean money money is not unimportant,
right?
But like it's not my only goal.
If I just wanted to make money, there
are a hell of a lot easier ways I can
just make money, right?
Spirit, it depends on your skill set,
Okay.
If you're like relatively new to the
space and don't really understand
everything that goes into this stuff, I
wouldn't consider it likely.
If you have deep knowledge of the space
and you can build something that's way
way better than everything that's out
there and you can turn it into something
reasonable, that's a different story.
Union fresh bread, then you're then
that's like a very difficult thing to
do, right?
Like you're picking an advanced area of
research.
and that that is more how I would look
at it, right? is like you do projects to
get better at stuff
to the point that you either can like
get a job that you want or start a
company around a project that you can
accomplish.
One of many other things.
Yeah, FBR's right on that. Not entirely
though.
I mean, there is money in the space and
there will actually be very soon a huge
huge amount of it, but
like not just free to pick up. You need
to actually learn what you're doing.
Lun says RL
and language models will not lead to
AGI.
I don't know. I give him a 5050.
Of
course, I'm taking the uh the 50% no bet
at the moment.
Only assume from automation, right, with
RL? No, there's tons of stuff we can do
with RL.
Honestly,
I think humanoid like at least humanoid
robots are going to be the most visible,
but kind of like the dumb
like the dumb future is here thing,
right?
like that's not actually the thing
that's going to make
uh that's going to like massively change
everything. I don't think
I mean I guess it depends what you care
about, right? like
how important do you think the
smartphone was versus the internet,
right?
Like in my mind at the very least, the
internet is this massive massive thing
and smartphones are just like not
Really?
You could tell me tomorrow that like,
you know, I got to ye my my phone and I
get like let's at least assume that you
have a reasonable keyboard, right? you
actually have like a reasonable touch
keyboard, but you have something that
just like can call and text and that's
it.
That doesn't make a huge change. I mean,
it really doesn't make a huge massive
difference for most stuff.
I didn't die in the 20110s
at all.
I guess in my mind, right, like the
consumer thing is like the least
interesting possible
possible thing to me.
Facebook could fly. Yeah, I never used
it. Like I had an account that I like
made cuz everyone had one I guess and
like people used the it for messaging
and like I always thought it was a net
negative
like total waste of life
even compared to other stupid [ __ ] you
can be
thinking what they're doing nonsense.
You should read my article.
I have this like kind of funny screw you
article on this.
So, this is a real thing. Um,
this is this is actually a real thing.
Uh, this is a real definition that I
came up with in like 2018 and I've used
ever since.
Where is it? Yeah,
it's very simple. AGI is here when I can
cast fireball. Until then, get back to
work.
I used this at OpenAI and uh people
didn't really know what the hell to say
about it back then
and I still use this today and it's
still more useful than anything else
anybody else proposes. This
I'm fully correct about this, right?
like, well, let me finish writing
Well, I like that definition because
it's like a shut up and start building
it definition,
but also it's like a it's kind of like
this techno optimist thing, right? where
it's like, hey, you know, a AGI is here
when we've built stuff that's like
literally like magic, right?
If I get fired, you have a full-time
contributor to popular will be branch
called agi.
Well, I hope you don't get fired, but I
do hope that you contribute some cool
stuff.
How do you bind C and Python files?
Like, how did you make the environments
of C by back in Python API using the C
API of Python?
So, Python has a native C API. It's a
little janky, but you can use it.
Puffer agent can cast. No, no, no, no.
Shadow, that's a copout. It's when I
personally can cast fireball. So that's
when there's AGI
hello Kyouong.
Oh, that old thing.
That's like the oldest joke that's in in
probably any of my repos.
I'll go click that. I That was probably
in 10 O.
That was just left in there as an Easter
egg.
[Music]
Yeah, Ken. I did three weeks worth of
hard research to make this stuff, like
to figure this stuff pallet.
Do you know New York RL conference? I
know there's like a meetup thing, Kevin.
And uh Eugene is I think it's Eugene's
thing, right?
It went through protein article
pretty good.
Yeah, protein article took a lot of
time. There's a lot of math. Well, the
the research for that did.
How do you manage your time? Do you make
a timet?
Uh, it's more free form these days. like
I get up around somewhere between 7 and
7:30
and
uh I get myself in shape to run as
quickly as I can. Usually have some
coffee or whatever first. I go run my
10K. I come back. I do my lifts. I go
get breakfast. Give my folks a quick
call. And then whenever the heck that
whatever the heck time that puts me at
depending on how quickly I do all that,
I do uh work. Either I have meetings or
I have, you know, stream and I do
several hours worth of work. I go take
myself to dinner and I go to bed. That's
pretty much it. Sometimes a little time
off in the evenings, sometimes not.
That's the current block that I've been
on for the last three weeks. It's not a
huge number of working hours. Um,
it's not like at least compared to the
heavier engineering stuff, but it's been
very effective for research.
Protein puffer no longer has wand
integration. That was janky, but useful.
Uh, Kyouong, we do have wand
integration, but not with wand sweeps.
You can run sweeps that are tracked on
wand. They're just not done through wand
sweeps. They're done through W's tags.
But yeah, it's just Kung. It's that you
just give a tag to whatever sweep it is
and then Puffer will just log like 200
independent runs and you just group it
by tag
and then you don't have to go through
W's sweeps interface which has a ton of
annoying problems.
And then this also works with Neptune
and it's very very easy to set this up
with like basically any tagged uh
tracker
cuz basically everything will always
have the ability to sort by tags,
Get the summary found in the title. What
has been done so far? Uh, 984 words
written and lots of random conversations
had with viewers.
Welcome, Jess.
We also found that it turns out one of
my viewers absolutely moss me in
ultramarathons which is was pretty damn
funny.
Yeah, it's uh so shadow it is it's an
oversight. Um I've been meaning to fix
it for a while, but like it could
actually change experiment perf and I
have to like rerun a bunch of stuff.
Basically,
it shouldn't be a huge thing cuz it's
like
you're at most one update stale on your
advantage computation, which is not even
a uh which doesn't even get back
propagated through.
But yeah, it is stupid
fundraising stream. I'm not really
looking to get um I'm not really looking
to fund this off of viewers and stuff,
Jess.
Like this is not
I really don't care about making Puffer
have like some small amount of user rev.
It's it's mostly like this is a project
that should be funded through uh large
contracts with industry.
I mean, we do we do offer that, right? I
should probably change this because this
makes it seem like most of our stuff
should be like 10K. Ideally, we're
looking for larger things at the moment.
Um,
but yeah, we do have like fixed
deliverable contracts that we offer.
So, you're at a company and you're doing
RL and you want the authors of the uh
fastest and most performant RL tools out
there looking at your problem and making
custom solutions. That is what we do.
any luck on that side? Yeah, I mean we
have uh we've got a couple of small
contracts and we're negotiating um
pilots
for larger companies at this point.
Is the end of itself that speed or is it
the uh the training?
That could be reasonable for training.
MPS is slow as hell.
SPS while training. 70% is training.
Not bad. I mean, you'd have to test like
the single core PF of chess, right, of
the engine.
I mean, one of the things I am working
on, right, is
I am working on getting Puffer to be
less reliant on ultra high perf Sim for
everything. Um, I think it's possible
that in the relatively nearish future,
we might be able to take like um a 10x
slower sim
and spend maybe, you know, four or five
times the compute we're spending now and
still have it work. Of course, it's
still it's four or five the compute to
be spent, but
better than uh better than nothing,
right?
initial thoughts on complexity versus
compute trade-off? What would it look
like?
Complexity versus uh depends what you
mean. Jog my memory. Open AAI are doing
a project called OpenAI client.
Is that just them like providing their
models to a bunch of scientists?
So far, I have not found these models to
be particularly good or useful for most
things.
Like the model needs to not just lie
half the time
is the problem.
like they just make [ __ ] up half the
time.
yeah, if you take a bad reviewer and
replace it. So like this is the thing
with AI, right? Most of the things were
like, oh, you could replace this thing
with AI, you're just saying this thing
is really bad and stupid and you could
replace it by not doing it, right? Like
you could also replace reviewers by just
not having review.
You could just change the process
because review is basically just wasting
everyone's damn time anyways. You could
just replace the review process.
That is an excellent observation.
Careful, you're starting to sound like
an LLM.
I do find it funny. Uh, opening his
agent mode. They're using effectively a
video model.
I don't know. I don't use it anymore.
basically this is a screenshot and user
text
They're no good physicsy libraries.
Yeah. I mean, for 2D, there's box 2D,
which is like optimized, but I really
don't like the way the um the API is.
Like, I
I really don't like the way it's like
you have this big engine and you give
stuff to the engine and then you step
the engine. It's like
3D. It's even worse. New dynamics and
bullet.
I think it's probably possible
if you actually know what you're doing
to make like um
a pretty minimal depending on what
features you want thousand to 2,000 line
single file physics library that's
actually good and fast.
I will say that for 2D, right, like you
get like a 100,000 steps per second with
uh Fox 2D on
uh whatchamacall
Impulse Wars. In simpler scenes, you can
get up to like a million steps per
second.
It's a lot faster, but it's
I don't I'm not a huge fan of the way
that the
like the internals I think are pretty
good. I'm not a huge fan of the way it's
all put together, though. 200's insane,
though.
Like the physics is just not that
expensive. It's not
an engineering buddy who would do good
work on something like that. Reminds me
a bit of Joseph. Depends on where he is
with his PhD. It's fun. I cannot get a
custom in my I've made one before++
was about five years ago. You definitely
want to like
you probably want to like go read what
the internals are in Box 2D and like
understand the algorithms bits a little
bit.
I mean, so here's the key thing, right?
It's like
you need to have a a good understanding
that you're targeting
you're targeting high performance sim
where simulation fidelity is going to
depend on the use case. So the goal is
not high fidelity physics first and then
you know everything else afterwards.
It's kind of like this joint problem.
I'm going to read this one more time and
I think that this is a good to go
article. Well, I need to get an image.
Rail is the best library.
I'm going to just real quick double
check that Um,
I'm just double-checking.
Sometimes I double check just to have
like a very noisy am I doing something
completely stupid. That's about the only
thing I use those for, though.
issues with friction because I over
complicated it grip make contacts be
sticky for now.
That's actually not a terrible thing to
do. Yeah.
I've honestly wondered a bunch of times
why they just don't do that with their
real robots, right? Like they do have
ones that use suction just so that they
don't have to bother with like modeling,
you know, grip contacts and stuff.
I've wondered why they don't just get
like some stupidly grippy material,
right?
forever because I don't want to have to
do that forever.
You don't know what curriculum
What in the hell?
Well, that's horrifying.
What the hell, Grock?
I'm going to just put the freaking
screenshot of the Cuda.
we go.
Have Gemini generate the image for you.
I mean, most of the AI like concept art
stuff kind of sucks anyways.
I think it's kind of funnier to just use
the uh
not even funnier but nicer to just use
the uh this is kind of like the coolest
piece of code in Puffer Lib in some
sense
because this is simultaneously
like a major PF enhancement and uh a
research contribution and the source of
like this entire discrepancy as well.
The Python bindings are cool, but like
the Python C API is kind of ass. So like
it's kind of difficult for me to write
something nice with that. This is like a
nice simple piece of code. This is like
a tiny little loop that does the whole
everything.
Yeah. Well, if I don't prompt engineer,
you just don't engineer.
I don't know why I can never spell that
word. Isn't this wrong?
Which one? this uh I remember I looked
this up because I remembered reading
this thing during some of my work. It's
just that it's limited, right? It
identifies the problem correctly, but it
doesn't identify the extent of the
problem because it's missing the context
of like modern HyperFRL,
right?
like they have the problem correctly
identified,
but then the thing that they're missing
here, right, is just how important the
longer form bootstrap is to onpaul RL
and how as a result of this like
off-paul methods basically just suck.
Like if you compare in the um the high
data regime, off-paul methods are just
bad algorithms,
right? They're bad but scalable.
I'm pretty damn sure as well there has
been work that like transformers are not
even necessarily better
um in the compute regimes that we're
dealing with.
LSTMs are just really fast
especially in the uh the RL setting
where you have like this like these
iterative rollouts. It's just really
good.
Where is the stupid thing?
What is this chat thing?
Did I get kicked out of it or is it just
still here? Hang on. No, it's here.
chat.
I'm a sucker for VAES. Did you see my
GAN GAN paper?
All right. This is the only generative
whatever the hell [ __ ] I've done.
Apparently, somebody cited it. Uh, where
is it?
All right. So, here was
like each of these rows are samples
generated by a different GAN and we
trained a GAN to output another GAN. You
learn a GAN over distributions of GAN.
So again, can you do the gan again? Yes,
you can.
I thought this was kind of cool, right?
Like you just train a bunch of different
GANs and you get like this weird
distribution, right?
Where like you can see that stuff kind
of changes.
like different digits are in different
resolution from different ones of these.
It's kind of funny.
I did this in three days,
including the paper. Like, this was a
long weekend project for me.
I wrote this awful I made this awful
figure,
but these were cool. It's just like a is
it a two-pager? Three pager.
Who the hell cited this thing? Did I
sight this thing?
I forget. Can you click this?
Whatever. I don't know. Can you even see
it?
saw it. That's funny. Yeah. Cool.
Okay. Uh I'm going to use a restroom
real quick and then we're going to see
what I do.
I'll be right back.
Uh, this does have some real research in
it, that guy. So, I did finally go and
publish uh a little bit of real research
here. Yeah,
that's a decent summary.
it. I probably could have written a
little bit more about world model stuff
because I did spend a lot of time on
that, but it's fundamentally
It's kind of all the same thing.
All
Yeah. So this is what the freaking paper
looks like even in the damn
preliminaries.
It's like a [ __ ] ton of math and then
you end up with actual PO which is just
like yeah just clip the damn update. So
what's the point?
Why would I cover this?
It's not even like I'm not giving credit
to the appropriate author because
Schulman. It's Schulman either way,
right? Generalized advantage estimation
in PORPO
Yeah, but you absolutely don't need to
like
I mean covering this is like making you
go through the thought process of actual
research, right? Like if I made you go
through the thought process of how I got
to the article that I wrote, it would be
10 times as long and way more
complicated, right? Like this is not you
actually don't need this. This is like
an intermediate product in a sense.
Like understanding this is not even
useful to understanding PO.
This is just going to confuse you.
It's interesting to me that actually we
don't get
it doesn't seem like we're getting any
benefit from multiple update epochs and
benefit at all from
Don't a lot of robotics things still use
separated
like separate
value and policy networks.
you can technically do the uh
like multiple epochs on the value
function, right?
though honestly I don't know the extent
to which that super matters.
Oh actually hey guys I think we
recovered something from this paper.
Wait, we totally recovered something
from this paper. Check this out.
I just realized this. I just made the
connection.
Okay, watch this. This is something cool
I just realized. So,
the original clean RL uh implementation
of PO, which is based on the OpenAI one,
has a value function coefficient. So the
multiplier of the loss of 0.5
where is it the PPG paper
says that you can uh improve PO by
training the value function for more
epochs in the policy.
So what's like a a kind of decent
approximation to that? It's just
increasing the coefficient of the value
function, right?
Well, in our sweeps and on our defaults,
we have a four times larger value
function co coefficient
and then we have heavy clipping
and the clipping prevents off
policyiness.
So actually what we end up doing is we
have a very heavy coefficient that's
clipped aggressively.
So I bet you that actually if we
implemented this thing we wouldn't get
anywhere near as much benefit as we see
in this paper because of uh the value
function coefficient difference.
I think I'm going to finish this up and
call it a little early today.
I think over the next couple days I
might take a bit of time off as well.
I can tell mentally I'm kind of just
burnt.
To be fair, I could probably also just
like
eat some damn food, but got to finish
the cut.
The only other paper
I suppose was somewhat interesting was
this one here.
They had like a moderate
improvement over PO, right?
But like then again, you never know if
like if we try the puffer implementation
if this just closes the gap completely.
Failing on one of these is kind of
sketch.
I think the experiments are super weak,
right?
I mean there are there is always the
chance that random Chinese paper just
solves things.
So, in the neural MMO 3 experiment, did
high info
replay buffer get updated and still?
Yeah. So yeah, Kyouong, if you uh
it does get wor it does do worse, but
that's not the point. So we know that
keeping off policy data monotonically
uh decreases performance in the simpler
tasks. The thing that was cool about it
was just by keeping around a tiny bit of
experience,
you're able to start learning a very
hard exploration task instantly.
So it's like it's basically a very
clear-cut motivation for wanting to have
sample reuse and then the fact that it
does worse later on like the only
explanation for that right is you've
just screwed it up with off policiness
Google's work with the RL work with the
improvers uh not my area I don't know
looks cool but I don't know anything
about
you slowly phase out the replay buffer.
You probably could do that, Kyouung, but
like it's a very very weak form of um
integrating like replay. Ideally, you'd
like to be able to have some way to just
integrate replay with your
um with your work regardless, right?
Like I think technically
if you had a separate value function and
policy function, I think you can do it.
I suppose you could also try to just not
train the value function on those
targets.
I don't know. There's probably some
stuff you could do.
Yeah, this is too much math and two weak
experiments.
Yeah, I mean it was meant as a
motivation, right, Kyouong? It's not
like, hey, this method is good. It's
more like, hey, we need to figure out a
way to use replay at some point.
I think I'm going to hop off this stream
soon. I've got an hour before I can go
to dinner.
Just freaking starving myself for the
last three weeks.
What do you think the next stream will
be on? Well, like I said in the article,
right, we're going to need to do a lot
of work on the tuning, like try to
retune Puffer for uh to basically model
that entire space. And then presumably
there going to be some additional
hardware optimizations we can make to
get a higher throughput in the lower
lower batch setting as well
as well as architecture stuff.
you directly attempt to learn the
results of the advantage rather than
value, but then you also still have to
learn value.
Now, I'll have to look at this in more
detail, I suppose. But I'm kind of shot
for the uh the time being, guys. I think
I'm going to like
we'll see what I do tomorrow, but I
think I'm going to take a little bit of
time. We're going to catch up on some
admin stuff. I'm going to get some rest
and then I'm going to think about
like how I want to set up the next
little block of research on this stuff,
right? I mean, realistically, the next
block of work should not be particularly
difficult. It's just like cleaning up
the way we do sweeps and reoptimizing a
bunch of stuff. Um,
so yeah, I'll take a little bit of time.
We'll do that and then there's more to
do from there.
Articles already starting to get some
attention. That's cool. All right. Um,
thank you folks. I'm going to call it a
day. I'll probably be back tomorrow. We
will see. I might also just do other
stuff tomorrow and like catch up on
things. We'll see. Um,
oh yeah,
if you're interested in my stuff
generally, sorry, GitHub, it's free.
Helps me out a ton. Discord for uh
getting involved with the project. And
other than that, you can follow me on X
for more RL content, including the
article I just posted. Thanks, and I'll
be back.